to rectify this situation microsoft made
a standards proposal that reconciles
touch events and mouse events and pen
input too into one model called pointer
events
so you'll notice that pointer events are
currently only natively implemented on
internet explorer and ie mobile for all
the other browsers out there you're
going to need a polyfill library built
on top of touch events
luckily there's a great polyfill library
out there as part of the polymer project
this is what i use to implement pointer
event handling in my synthesizer the set
of pointer events should look pretty
familiar to you if you've used mouse
events before
they basically map all the mouse events
directly and then add the pointer cancel
event from touch as well the pointer
event itself derives from mouse event so
it gets all the same coordinates as
mouse events as well as a few things
from touch it has a unique pointer id
similar to that touch id we saw in touch
events
and it also has a width and a height of
the touch point in touch cases
for pen cases it may have pressure or
tilt
and of course the pointer event tells
you what type of pointer it is whether
it's a mouse pointer or a touch pointer
or a pen input